on this episode we talk a bay we leave
the office and go see Nate and we answer
some other questions that I just can't
recall right now you ask questions and I
answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 90 on the ask gary vee
show very good job by john Troutman here
at vaynermedia who grew up with me in
the wine world worked at a corked and
has been at Vayner a long time
he uh he emailed stunwin and I write
Steve last night said by doing this
episode the askgaryvee show has now had
a monumental moment it has now become
the second most episodes show in my
career because the little-known fun fact
is a thousand episodes of Wine Library
TV eighty-nine episodes of the
mobile-only daily grape
so now askgaryvee on this moment makes
the big leap to being in the number two
spot only 911 the go-to to match Wine
Library I don't think we'll get there
let's hope we can get to eleven more and
had hit a hundred or ten more I guess
it's 90 so uh feel good the trip to uh
thanks for all of you that followed me
on my snapchat story my 24 hours to
Spain and back the beard is coming in
really nice and it's really getting
there and and that's the scoop so uh
India let's get into the show
don't over so my question is about the
new fountain app I recently became one
of the beta experts in the fashion and
beauty part of it and I wanted to know
your thoughts on people using video to
ask questions and do you think that they
will pay for it to ask questions and
have them answered I an expert of your
answers Thanks right dawn this is a
tremendous question with a very
important answer I I think that people
will pay for anything let me say that
again people will pay for anything if
they perceive it has value if there was
an askgaryvee show in 1967 and I'd be
like hey groovy cats it's the askgaryvee
show
you know really excited Oh dawn you're
thinking like well people pay for water
are you that's totally far out that's no
way like that would be the wrong answer
what happened was pone Springs and I'm
sure plenty of people long before Poland
Springs I'm just not educated on the
early days of the water industry people
along and convinced people that bottled
water had value I mean you go ask your
grandparents there's a little fun
weekend challenge go with ask your
grandparents what they first thought if
they can remember not cuz they're old
just like if they can remember what they
thought about the idea of people paying
for water think about how you feel
save how do you feel on the notion that
I mean I don't know if you know this but
you have at certain times paid three to
four dollars for a bottled water at an
airport or some scenario you absolutely
have done it what do you think about
that yeah I mean it's it's a absolute
brain twist people will pay for answers
even though so many people are watching
right now you have a free show here that
you don't pay for answers from somebody
very qualified thank you very much but I
do think people will pay now are you
good enough have you built up enough
brand equity and have you created the
perception of the value to your answers
to have that be the case for you and
more importantly how many unicorns are
there to be able to do that how many
people have built up enough historical
execution and have charisma and ability
to answer how many Jack Welsh is how
many Mark Zuckerberg and then more
importantly the people that have
actually pulled it off have to be in a
very interesting part of their career or
enjoy it I love QA so much that I have
to do this show for me for happiness not
for the ROI on the time I'm sure it's
building audience there's a lot of good
variables sure it'll be a right hook
with the askgaryvee book but the truth
is the amount of money I'm going to make
on the book is shorter than if I did six
speeches so you know it doesn't make
sense mathematically and so a lot of
people that would be good enough to pull
off having people answer for them would
never want to do that as a business like
you know so I think it's an interesting
challenge what I would say is there's
probably uniquely a hundred to ten
thousand people that look the part
similar to be very honest with as much
humility as I can possibly say this
similar to me that can probably pull it
off to a meaningful scale my intuition
is there's a
a lot of people that can get eight
people to pay to answer their question
but that's not real zach asks what three
questions do you most commonly ask your
clients when meeting them for the first
time
Zach wonderful question for everybody in
client services agency life this should
be fun you know number one is what is
your KPI what's your key performance
indicator like what is the thing that
you want us to accomplish is it views is
it sales is it perception is a press is
it is it your own judgment on how you
feel about the creative how are you
judging us what are the results and
they're really separate how are you
judging us what are the results our
number 1 a and 1 B that matters the most
and then really the third one would then
be what are you willing to tell me about
your warts meaning there's just a lot of
people that are not gonna tell you about
the politics that are an issue the money
that's an issue I'm always trying to get
them to be very truthful for us to us
once I understand what the issues at
hand are so what do you really want to
accomplish by the way people struggle
with answering that people struggle with
answering that number two how you gonna
judge me sometimes they struggle that
less number three what are the warts
most people don't want to tell me
upfront we try to sniff them out early
so we can navigate them and you know
it's like it's a minefield to get to the
finish line they're three and and
they're and they're very important
questions and trying to figure out in
every situation and absolutely every
situation in dating in building your own
business and having clients I really
think those three are super fun and by
the way they're very important equally I
think for example I think people that
struggle with dating are spending way
too much on number three they're so
concerned about what the person's warts
are skeletons in their closets they're
not trying to figure out how they're
being judged to be a good partner in
that relationship or how that's gonna be
scored and so having a great balance of
all three that's a little nugget there
give you a little fun fact at the end of
this question it's the 33% execution of
those three questions that may be
equally as important yeah now yeah that
that got to be a better article because
I learned that last piece what's going
on a meerkats team somebody sorry guys
if they're conflicted about whether they
should watch live of your cat away -
that's a really interesting question
what are you whatever we both well of
course but one in Everybody wouldn't
everybody's saying how many people in
their hundred eighty two thirty - good
yeah personal Brees
yeah interesting well everybody I'm your
cat get on Instagram take a picture
ask the question hashtag askgaryvee and
maybe you can be on the show specie
suckers
oh no Kathleen says speaking of dating
where's me mate yeah where is it Nate
let's go see where nate is I'm taping
askgaryvee and Kathleen is it a meerkat
I just got a notification that
Kathleen's curious where you are so here
you are why don't you give the
vaynernation you know two seconds of
what you've been to Kathleen
specifically but what have you been
really doing today
working on budgets and scopes primarily
I think it sounds suit berry riveting a
lot of spreadsheets Excel are you
teaching Alec young Alex the ropes so we
got a scope open right there I love it
well don't show the scope all right
let's get back to the show thanks Nate
yes I think Kathleen is in Australia I
like that Nate has secret admirers get
in there oh nice job Stefan
d-roc might not get his gig back with
that move right there that was a very
smooth transition uh charts do come true
sound cursor asks three seconds counting
is a view for facebook video moderately
misleading metric or incredibly [ __ ]
Metro so this is a great question Kevin
but before I get into the question that
picture is ah adorable big shout-out
vaynernation you can learn from the
creativity of that picture when you ask
a question look I think first of all
marketing right now in general is a got
a real problem of with over depth right
so you know is three seconds pre-roll
view on Facebook bullcrap compared to
people buying views on YouTube as
pre-rolls
that are you know I'm not sure if that's
one two or three seconds but there
pre-rolls their actual ads whereas
Facebook is putting it in fee
you know I don't know I mean I think
look I don't care about with metrics to
begin with any brand startup that is
saying oh this got 8 million views or
it's got 87 views and that's the
definition of success doesn't realize
that technology can gain that game and
so the interesting part is I'm not
worried about that metrics I'm looking
at the engagement the comments the click
throughs to the product or whatever else
you're trying to do or I'm taking the
width for the width value if I want a
hundred thousand people or five hundred
thousand people to at least see my face
once in their lives that three seconds
made them do that it depends on what
you're trying to drive it's similar to
question number one on the show today
what is the KPI if the KPI is the number
of views you should be challenging that
as your KPI in a world with YouTube and
Facebook
counting the way they're counting Steve
your smile you're enjoying the
conversation in meerkat yeah good
the maple parlor asks what's your best
piece of advice for a first generation
American entrepreneur venturing out on
her own away from her family business
April first and foremost India just
shared some other photos from your
Instagram besides your question and your
product looks delicious there's a pretty
known thing amongst the most hard
vayniacs is that when I go on book tour
I always start up Powell's in Portland
so you know I'm on this hardcore diet
but I think we may have to sneak in when
we do that February March April next
year and try you out you know look I
think I think the biggest thing that I
tell everybody is number one
practicality how much money do you have
to stay alive for how long that is
always my biggest fear first time
entrepreneurs make this mistake do you
have one year's worth of rent and
overhead and then you have to make your
actions respond to your bleeding of cash
before you turn a profit when you start
a new business especially an ice cream
parlor you know a restaurant kind of you
know what you're doing you've got to
make sure that you know you're putting
up up front investment financially not
just time it's not like you're building
something with code you're literally you
know paying rent and buying supplies and
so you need to have a high level of
practicality the other thing that I tell
entrepreneurs that are more practical
again a physical location you know it
sounds like the way you asked a question
that you're leaving your own family's
business and doing your own thing you
know hopefully it's not competing
directly with your own family's business
so there's not some weirdness I think
the thing that you really need to pay
attention to is you have made a decision
that does not allow you in year one any
time to do anything but build your
business you are not allowed you're
almost not even allowed to watch the
askgaryvee show going forward like you
are in such a Code Red
zone that every minute call it 18 hours
a day out of 24 if you want this to be
successful need to be allocated for your
business you know even at the mercy in
year one of your family time even at the
mercy of that and so I guess what I'm
getting at and you could tell by my tone
and vibe
and I think one of the biggest reasons
so many people go out of business in the
first year first two years small
business practical word of their burning
cash is they don't realize how hard it
is and how all-in you have to be and so
if you really want this dream to come
true you've got to make substantial
sacrifices hey Gary Vee Michael Pearce
here and I have a question regarding
platforms to sell your merchandise
online I run an online community
designed to help other sellers succeed
on platforms like eBay Amazon and
through systems like Amazon FBA just
recently probably the last six months
there's been a lot of talk of eBay
really going downhill a lot of sellers
are fed up with their fees and they're
really disliking the path that eBay is
taken my question for you is if I Bay
doesn't innovate if they don't change if
they don't get out of this old-school
mentality do you think they'll become
irrelevant in the next five or ten years
do you think places like Amazon will
completely take over the entire market
rather than just owning a majority of it
right now named Michael great question
you know I'm an eBay head Tod AJ had to
be an entrepreneur by going to garage
sales and selling on eBay you know e
beings become more Amazon like than what
it originally started out which was sell
Pez dispensers and bobbleheads and
beanie babies you know I actually think
there's a huge white space so I think he
may is doing the right thing believe it
or not competing a little bit with
Amazon
I do think resellers are struggling it
with with it but manufacturers and
people at scale are enjoying it I think
I think what eBay is doing is they're
recognizing there's no alternative to
eBay in the world so ironically I think
the white space says I'm gonna make a
prediction here in the next and I don't
like doing predictions I always say I
don't make predictions I just follow but
I'm gonna make one and I and I failed in
a startup called yard sale Mobile eBay
and I may be wrong and I actually feel
pretty weak about this prediction but
I'm gonna make it anyway I do think that
in the next 10 years
somebody's gonna build eBay again eBay
is so much not eBay anymore that when
you look at it it's all new products
like I still think there's enormous
Commerce in used product and so exci
took its own kind of crafter mold
ironically that's you just went public
yesterday so interesting timing eBay is
eBay but is evolving more towards Amazon
like you know you know overstock retail
I think there's a huge open space for
somebody to build a billion-dollar
company in literally just becoming eBay
and lick and I mean restrictions no new
products everything on the site is used
you know used I just I think it's a huge
place though especially with mobile and
smart there's so much I'm curious where
that goes so you know do I think Amazon
could be the entire marketplace no do I
think that eBay is gonna go out of
business next ten years no I actually
think what eBay is doing is actually
smart for their business until this
alternative comes which may never come
thus I'm pretty I'm pretty positive and
so on their direction and so I think if
you guys are resellers or a certain type
of niches that I mean I've been saying I
mean me my homies that sold collectibles
said eBay was finished not as good as it
was in 2005 like the IE buddies ruined
that was 10 years ago so that's my
answer question of the day I'm so into
eBay I need everybody's got one
I need your eBay you know what this is
gonna be the first time I'm gonna read
every single comment over the weekend
cuz I really love this go in-depth
vaynernation
I need your eBay story
also real quick quick right hook for
them but listening on the podcast and
watching the askgaryvee show
I need the follow on Instagram about to
do something really interesting so ping
up here Instagram if you're not
following me enormous mistake username
at Gary Vee and thank you for everybody
who uh who has given me tons of snapchat
love I'm enjoying that as well at Gary
Vee ten more two hundred see you soon
you keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
historically since I don't eat it at
this point anymore historically I'm a
mushrooms and peppers guy
[Music]